hey everybody and welcome to the Shan
method i'm sean mckenna and this is
chris waters hello and we had a bit of a
situation we're going to play Sleeping
Dogs today there's a whole thing with a
save file and in it not working so as a
backup we're going to go back to a game
that we played previously on the show
which we had a really good time with we
figured let's see what's new with Russ
Russ Russ yeah I'm making boots John is
making some clothes for himself so that
he does not pull an esclavos those of
you who watch the last episode knows
esclados glados come on i SPECT the man
and his monster dong I'm so sorry last
time we had an encounter with a
pantsless wonder which proved to be
illuminating yeah something was
illuminated it was his penis all right
everybody how you doing Oh what how's it
going I'm gonna take out this it here
team up and should we try to get this
deep let's tag team this dear try
crouching man whoa crouching you mean
like you mean like stealth that's a
pretty good one okay dude this is some
next-level [ __ ] dude you'll come in for
him in the tall grass anybody I want you
to be my friend so that we can go on
adventures together and maybe form an
intimate relationship but that comes
second you're being a little transparent
being a little too transparent being
what's all this whoa this dude is
sleeping on the ground that dude is this
asleep yeah that dude is just straight a
slit isn't a live person asleep oh yeah
that dude logged off oh he's got why are
you stealing his water yeah hell yeah
I'm stealing him are you gonna murder
him in the night I mean this is the day
shakin height sweet prince oh no you're
mining him for door oh he might already
be dead that looks like a dead person
that's totally how do you sleep I don't
excuse me
how are you doing my friend whoa there's
good shots whoa it's okay run okay we're
friends we're friend we're fine be cool
fine don't you worry about ah GD it I
lost all my good stuff so turns out when
you hear gunfire and you run over there
this is a very good chance you're gonna
get shot and murder killed you got hit
in the torso with an m4 yeah by a
someone named I'm very powerful oh that
dude is still up here hey dude hey dude
hey hey hey guy guy guy guy you're in
the red shirt you in the red shirt I
just want you to know that even though
you killed me I give you is that the
same one bunch of children hey guy in
the red sweatshirt hey I'm seriously
concerned that you're not even
acknowledging me oh look here's the
party it's one thing to kill a dude and
then quick I need to negotiate a truce
that dudes about the more I just want
you thats a guy who killed you I just
want you to know that I all they're both
true to you they're all should there's
three of them they're a whole game I'd
like to join your sweet gang I offer my
services anything I can do to help you
out are you go fix your negotiation
skills our town oh look hey guys hey
guys you need a third for your gang of
sweet dudes cuz I am perfectly willing
to help out yeah all right cool let's go
where you guys heading I know its weak
spot oh you know you know it too it's
the butt of the bear look that dude is
tithing the bear come on get in there
man need to contribute Oh dudes that was
sick nice work on that bear these guys
are these guys are all about it they're
hustling all right you could leave now
wait hold on i thought we had joined a
gang together are you sure because i
felt like we had a moment back there
guys i just want you to know the Sun is
about to go down and eventually it's
gonna a situation is going to arise
where we're gonna have to share body
warmth I just want you to know that I'm
okay with that if it I you could build a
leer all right cool I mean usually I
prefer big spoon but I'll do little
spoon
measure me oh yeah what yeah yeah no
totally it's dark out let me light the
way for you from behind were you talking
to the board just now when you said get
away yeah okay good just just checking
oh yeah I think you guys made a mistake
you accidentally shut the door before I
could come in there I know it's a the
doors in this game are tough to work but
it seems like you accidentally shut it
before I could come in I just want you
to know that guys it's okay you can open
the door anytime I mean it's not like
I'm I'm angry or anything it's just that
it's it's awkward is all that I'm saying
guys can you can you open the door guys
here okay I'll help you out I don't know
if they're going to like it that you're
knocking on their door with a boulder or
you've been hitting the door guys it
seems like you have like a broken lock
or something on your so I'm just going
to help take care of it I'll be out here
for a little while you just let me know
if you get a fixed from the inside I'll
just be out here it's cool don't worry
about it guys guys what is even going on
you have a fire in there is a look at
it's so cozy in there guys I can see you
from the cracks in here I can see that
you guys are having a good time you're
cooking some chicken meat and you're not
letting me in and that's I'm not just
gonna say that's weird that's okay I'll
start a fire right outside maybe you got
to smoke him out guys guys the ring of
ticket bye guys I'm worried that you're
trapped inside so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to build a trail of
campfires from the road to your house so
that may be a skilled locksmith can come
along and get you out of there because
I'm just worried that you're trapped
inside that's the thing as I'm just
worried about you is all guys it's very
generous of you Shawn oh [ __ ] oh my
goodness
it was the hundreds of fires the thing
was the fires what they did not like
this dude go hello there hi I was
wondering if I could offer my services
to you as a teammate I do not have good
items but I'm very loyal and I'm
expertly skilled at killing red bears
would you like would you like to team up
is that a no jump once for no jump twice
for yes you forgot to note the second
time that's pretty vigorous know so
that's a no you don't want to team up
give it 10 seconds before he takes a
swing at you okay do you perhaps know
where I can meet some new people because
I'm desperate for companionship this way
oh it is just off oh that player oh yeah
this way maybe you could just follow
that player all right sure that I'll
follow you I'm I do is that your music
wash that your music vengaboys 420
around are you blasting tight beats oh
hey guys how's it going you guys want to
have a dance party why is that do trying
to murder my buddy whoosh oh that guy's
the hacker I think you did look you is
literally friendly guy hey friendly guy
tell him your friends hey friendly guy
i'm also a friendly guy and i was
wondering if you wanted to form a gang
and run around and do good deeds for
people quickly all right quite no we
don't have time all right yeah we have
Oh hells bells we gotta go friendly guy
there's no time to waste chasing us we
don't have time run away god damn it oh
[ __ ] rock guys right behind me turn
around and hit it with a rock
defend yourself friendly guy where is it
that guy is speed hacking you will never
be about oh oh oh hello is that you
friendly guy oh did you Oh friendly guy
hey oh my God we're back alright let go
yeah the gang is back together am i
right we have y'all gonna look out for
him yeah don't trust that Mad Max guy he
was hacking wall hacks probably yeah we
retrospectively lose her real convincing
laughs yeah dying is hilarious oh god
he's mad max is back mad max is back
turn around no there's no time I have to
run straight ahead never look back what
you're looking back sometimes you can
look back whoa why does that do just
speed hacking to do murder do you think
that friendly guys is luring us in there
Oh Eric hey guy I think you should find
friendly guy again hey outlaw biker I
have a question for you do you have a
microphone no okay here's a question
would you like to form a gang with me
and go around and do justice to people
oh look it's friendly guy who's totally
not in on the con luring us to the
hackers hey friendly guy good to see you
again yeah but have you noticed that
both times I know but you did here's
here's where to get 30 feet of the game
without dying I'm just going to say this
I've been killed by those hackers twice
and both times i've been lured over
there by you so fool me once etc I
didn't intentionally lure you I think it
keeps using confirmation
I don't think that's confirmation bias I
think that there's a clear clear
correlation between me dying and you
luring me to my death you sir have a
very very small sample size to make such
such a huge assumption that's true it's
a small sample size however it is a one
hundred percent success rate and me
getting murdered it's hard to early
numbers give it another could be some
extrinsic factors in play alright
alright that's fair you won me over with
extrinsic factors how about this we go
off and we do adventures and hopefully
we don't get speed hacked okay outlaw
biker you're coming with us whoa you
actually do have a house holy [ __ ] okay
what do you think so I was thinking the
name of our gang should probably be the
wild stallions drop the wild stallion
just wild stallion or maybe just wild
stallions I'm not sure we need the
article may I see your metal one by one
you may I don't don't get any designs on
that though fine at the middle made of
one hundred percent of your iron all
right go in no no sorry sorry but you
have to be a member of wild stallions
because i was gonna raid this so i could
have a metal one by one thank you for
your honesty that's probably not a thing
you should do with the GD wild stallions
family go i played with you before
what's happening yeah just like some
weird with all the shooting going honey
some posturing happening I think you
have the wrong yeah this friendly guy's
legit guy he's telling you about
friendly guys murders in the past he's
revealing his true nature hey killer cat
how about this you have to come on a
loyalty quest with me and prove your
worth to wild stallions you want to do
that if you need to clear that with crew
call the crew is called wild stallions
you haven't officially decided no we did
we did we officially decided while
shellings it was a two-to-one vote
outlaw bikers way would do good all
right Keller cat killer cat you're
coming with me you ready you ready for
this bro he's ready up oh no kill a cat
are you dad did you die oh did you just
one shot kill her cat oh yeah that's
killer cat he's dead um so outlaw biker
bad news Joe a cat he had an incident
and he might have died I don't know how
it happened he just kind of died drinks
things happen yeah and the mange things
happen in the night friendly guy outlaw
biker got killed and so did killer cat
killer quo god bless Oh quick put out
the alright trip it Ryan motion sir but
you have to run in a zigzag pattern
family guy that's the only way to avoid
getting shot where's in oh no killer cat
came back with a vengeance oh killer cat
yahoo when did killer cat acquire a
shotgun the wild stallions ride no more
wild stallion did a good run though that
was loud yeah I did have a good run
that's true that was good uh thanks for
watching folks we had some great support
in the twitch chat and on the game SWAT
comments much appreciated oh my god on
how are you feeling rust but this game
is pretty much evergreen for Shawn
method it's fun yeah are we still
getting the audio on this good we're
still getting you really want to see the
killer cat really wants to get in there
here's what if you guys want to join I
recommend going to the what server am I
first one I'm in yeah u.s. East rest
calm this one here join it give killer
killer cat a hand you know this guy is
desperate this guy needs some help in
life desperate he is a shotgun yeah
that's true it's not desperate man he's
probably dead for all right that's
enough wow that's enough all right
everybody to look at thanks for watching
the show we really appreciate it Chris
waters yeah when is your show next
Tuesday 00 could respond inside the
house yeah uh we got the lobby multiple
players next Tuesday and also the review
for titanfall will be live next Monday
yeah exciting and tomorrow random
encounter at 11am followed by a megabit
11am on friday yep gamespot programming
watch them it's fun we're really glad
you guys watched thank you see you guys
later bye